[Applaudissements]
super content ce soir
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
franchement franchement ça fait plaisir
et en plus je suis en stress totalisé
chine ou si on va commencer par
présenter les chroniqueurs je crois que
c'est comme ça que ça marche à vous
connaissez plus que moi on commence avec
le plus beau à ya les bras fort
un peu comme mes cuisses un même si
qu'il a des cuisses en peut pas mener
bras
[Applaudissements]
mathieu à ça va super ils nous ont dit
on à leurs hôtes certes ce que tu veux
quand t'es très d'antara j'adore ce sera
sérieux mais gilles entraînons connard
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ce c'est lé grand bien on
continue elle est belle elle est en elle
est talentueuse pardon elle est bien
coiffée ils sont frappés lesquels joue
du piano famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il adore 7,9 c'est gentil merci prochain
chroniqueur il est journaliste il a
travaillé aux figures oui ça ce que
personne n'a réussi à le trouver
d'ailleurs c'est son anniversaire ce
qu'on peut exactement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est indécent de vous
montrer de vous demander votre âge 54 54
ah ouais comme celle ci génome encore on
accompagne à toulalan qui la donnent
toujours bien on continue avec le
prochain un prochain jeu l'adorent
vraiment son humour voilà il faudrait me
faire ma première partie à l'olympia
mais qui s'étale au vainqueur mais
justement monsieur thierry moreau
bienvenus
j'espère que ce soir ce soir on a tous
les droits et vous allez droit de faire
n'importe qu'elle va en faire une vanne
loblaw hills en somme taurion du tour
non mr bean moi j'adore votre humour les
jeux de mourir est sorti quatre ans avec
lorie kane 5 mars on continue avec je ne
sais plus j'ai perdu voilà le prochain
le prochain et inspire quoi jean marc et
12 pièces on a peur on a fait une petite
surprise avec vous tous c'est vraiment
s'est éclaté avec vous monsieur gilbert
d'elle
[Applaudissements]
même grosse surprise en moyenne 10 kg
ayant et pourtant j'ai tant des
brésiliens on continue avec avec la
demoiselle du plateau voilà elle est
adorable un look d'enfer oui la carte de
fidélité ont nagé avait déjà dit jouan
plus
[Applaudissements]
voilà trois sillage lc l'écolier qui
sont gênants on continue avec enora et
ravissante elle est blonde elle a déjà
son titre au râteau en danger les jouer
les touches et son cas est vrai jeu je
précise non foetale et restent à quai je
continue à tous casse la gueule on s'est
initiée aux frères je suis super content
jean luc lemoine s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
mais bon je suis super content parce
qu'il attend non je suis pas content
parce que j'ai fait une de mes premières
scènes avec jean lui qui m'avait
présenté vraiment un moment que je garde
ça à lille est un troll q tu as au temps
du quartier arrive à dire que t'es un
connard merci donc monsieur jean luc
jean luc lemoine est présentée mais tu
te rappelles plus de monde quand même
ouais encore il souviens toi de tout de
tout parce qu'il ya des dossiers avec
toi merci doit alors on continue avec
klose ont entendu un portage en a oublié
ta oublier quelque chose là n'ont jamais
oublié c'est une émission à loin c'est
moi qui présente tant à nominer ont
fouillé dans les chiottes au vent des
rockies un concours non il faut le fond
on a dit à l'américaine c'est l'herbe et
non mesdames et messieurs les 10e jeux
qu'on a agressé à coup que clouston
durant la séance
[Applaudissements]
là
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore plus tôt
[Applaudissements]